es gibt ja es gibt sie immer so oder so
dass frauen als quant errichten oder
gibts gabe einzelne 1 in gibt es
einzelne gibt es immer aber aber im
großen und ganzen
früher war das gängige praxis und so ist
immer also da hat sich einiges getan
bin wirklich froh was so zb 80er
jordanier song was zur
gleichberechtigung zwischen mann und
frau genau frau zwischen mann und frau
hat sie einiges was sie einiges getan
doch auf alle fälle sie müssen ja bloss
einmal in einen drogeriemarkt neige ging
also in einem drogeriemarkt seien
inzwischen ganze wände seien voll mit
pflegeserien für männer pflegeserien für
männer sollten früher am anführer
pflegeserie gehabt steht die fernseher
von verschlafen
unser vorschlag modus ganz so erfährt
man so hart ist der ist am marktplatz
und brunner kling in der früh sein soll
hierüber mit durchgesetzt
es war so jedenfalls in ingolstadt
pflege ist er die fragen wir aber
manchmal diese männer die so lege sehr
ian her immer sang gestern hat
eigentlich diese neuen männer oder zur
forderung der das mögen männer drei
haben das war so 80er jahre das sagen
was man als schlagersängerin gehen wenn
sie ein erinnern ist was erklären wie zu
ganz kurze ob fressen und schuhmachern
hause
ina deter bethaus kosten und die absolut
kommt neue männer braucht das land im
text ist immer vorkommen
ich schreibe an jede wand neue männer
braucht das land
was dem sinne vorweg endlich mit diesem
blöden unterdrücker schweinen
wir brauchen neue männer männer dieser
satz macht so was aus wenn es im
wohnzimmer bisschen lauter wert weil ich
mir halt nur staub saugen wie vor in der
küche weiter
solche männer wobei aber nicht sicher
bin ob es dann diese männer die susan ob
es dann wirklich hat diese männer sind
die letztendlich von der damenwelt
bevorzugt werden beziehung zwischen mann
und frau ist unglaublich schwierig die
schwierigste aufgabe und die habe zyklus
herausgefunden und ich war überrascht
vom ergebnis
ammann liegt es nicht
dass dabei wie plus taste klatscht aber
na wie geht's tony martin war total
überrascht
ammann liegt es wirklich nicht weil es
ist doch so es ist doch so wenn der mann
und frau beziehung eigener dann dauert
es doch mit langer sagte mann du schatz
sagen wir einfach wie gehabt diese das
den user und dann bin ich so und beim
gipfel keine probleme mehr oder
und genau da fangen die probleme weil
frau meier frau vordermayer frau wie
schaut ein ideal mann aus in der regel
songs enisa haben wir zum beispiel
ach ja also ich finde er muss so etwas
darstellen also er muss groß sein wie
ich und so muskulöse bislang
waschbrettbauch moussa haben und ich sag
immer er der früher auch ein bisschen
macht es sei also war macho der fall sei
aber sensibel
er muss sehr sensibel muss es sein er
muss über seine gefühle reden können und
ich habe nichts dagegen wenn man ab und
zu mal weint ich darf das kurz
übersetzten
frauen wie in so eine art bruce willis
deren ganzen tag blickt liebe damen
sie müssen jetzt ganz stark sein sollen
wir uns nicht grämen
so schaut ganz schlecht aus
wahrscheinlich rhythmen sorgen der
bloßen ganzen blickt verstehst und den
kindern an ideen haben und dann aus
diesen schulen studien verliert
verstehst er fliegt hinaus wie die
scheiße aus der ganz das ist ja logisch
[Applaus]